thank you so much for having me I'm
thrilled to be here well the last time I
saw you was actually like at the
Saturday Night Live Co testing area and
I'm not really like a
schmoozer and so I'm shy so I was
like hi you were shy I was just about to
do Saturday Night Live I've never been
so nervous in my entire life and I saw
your face and it was like an instant
balm oh I it was there are moments where
you kind of need like a little bit of a
life and I looked over and saw you and I
was like today's going to be okay the
nerves are going to be fine
yeah see that's so funny I would never
have assumed you would ever think that
in my mind here's my inner dialogue oh
my god there he is he's so amazing okay
keep it cool don't bother him all right
you know what you regret it if you don't
say hi say hi don't be a say hi but it
is like nerve-wracking to meet your
heroes or people you love especially if
you happen to have social anxiety which
I do
that's like an extra extra layer it's
not just like is this person special and
I want to meet them it's also just like
I'm uncomfortable in the room generally
speaking most of the time okay let's get
into it good greef I'm dying I loved it
so much oh thanks this movie not only is
it cinematic and romantic and poetic and
fun and funny and I cried a lot in it
too this is the single greatest review
I've ever heard this is amazing we'll
just use those words
what is so beautiful about this film as
it unfolds as this beautiful love story
and what we go through it's really
steeped in the friendships we are in to
order in order to survive life yeah and
then those friendships have intricacies
and needs and yet you have a scene where
um the incredible Ruth like has a date
where she's meeting a guy on a dating
but he comes to meet with you guys and
your friends I've never had a date from
the app I'm on come and meet me with
friends I been doing this all wrong no
but I think it was something I've never
had that either by the way I mean I
could barely find a date on the dating
app I never find a date on the app well
that's not true the only dates I've gone
on in the last seven years which are
very few and far between are from an app
interesting are you on an app I am on an
app me too I wonder if we're on the same
app I wonder as well I mean listen I've
been single for a while okay me too and
when you are unpartnered you turn to
your friends in ways that are so
meaningful especially like in your 30s
and 40s the older you get the more
meaningful your friendships become
because your lives take on a weight that
they didn't in your 20s and this was
about taking all of those characters
putting them in the middle of a movie
and saying this is the movie pay
attention to Friendship too yes our
lives can't only be dictated by like
romantic love if you don't have that
right now that's okay hold your friends
close cuz that love story is just as
important